what are we doing tomorrow about the
show let's assume that they know what
they're talking about with this storm
and it's so bad
that we can't get to work there there
will be a decision made you know tonight
right and uh we have a show we can run
tomorrow if need be right i have a
feeling that tonight they will close the
bridges and the tunnels now let's so
what if they do that are you in the city
tonight i'm not oh you're going back
home yes almost every almost everybody's
going back home well why would you go
back home if we're doing a show tomorrow
because i think the feeling for most
people is that they have a wife and kids
in a house
that also needs to be protected
so what are you going to do how are you
going to protect how are you going to
protect in other words if a tree falls
in the house what the [ __ ] is my wife
going to do what are you what are you
going to do he's going to lift it i'm
going to lift it off samson
i'm like marty jo young so i can't count
on you to be here tomorrow i will be
here because you've decided
you said that if if people it's pretty
clear that it might be very bad and you
might not be able to get into the city
right so you're abandoning ship am i
correct that is not correct if i can get
into i'm just i'm trying to make an
assessment if i can say you're not so in
other words if it's a bad storm you
won't be able to get in right
because you you're not going to stay
over in the city correct that's correct
all right
and that that would be i would say most
of the people i didn't ask about most
people i just asked about you mm-hmm
okay
why not bring mary and lucas into the
city today and and now because
what are you guys [ __ ] crazy so robin
you would leave your house yeah so if a
tree falls on my house i'll just figure
it out when i get home yeah of course in
your house why do you want to be in it
what if it starts to flood
yeah what are you gonna do
well i have some i have a pump that i
could you know hook up and start to try
to get the water out do you think that's
gonna work i don't know but i would
rather do that than do nothing i see
i don't think you see no no i just asked
you are you gonna be here tomorrow and
now you're getting defensive because i
have you are feeling guilty i'm not
feeling guilty listen to your voice
you're yelling but you you're not you
there's nothing i have all i say there's
no idea you're going to be here tomorrow
there's no sensitivity to somebody's
family or home i didn't i said you go i
asked you you said no here's what here's
the difference i'm going to point that
out i'm going to get you right here go
ahead you said oh so i guess i can't
depend on you right you i can't depend
on you to be here tomorrow am i correct
i don't think that's wrong am i right
you just said that's what i said and you
said that's not how i said it
i can't depend on you can i hear you
it's different that i can't depend gary
can i depend on you to be here tomorrow
if the weather
can i depend on you to be here tomorrow
is there is it an absolute that'll be
here tomorrow the answer is no okay
that's all i asked but you say can i i
guess i can't depend on you
i can't depend on you to be here
tomorrow am i correct
there's two different versions can i
depend on you to be here tomorrow is one
thing can i depend on you if you don't
say anything that means i can't depend
on you no matter what no i said tomorrow
can i depend on you to be here and you
said no that is correct but then you
went through a whole beaver-toothed
explanation about how
all but you asked me i don't know you
said you were getting defensive but you
said why i said what and then i told you
and you spent the night in the city then
you told i told you why and then because
you need to be there with me completely
discounted i did not i just said you did
are you going to be and then robin asked
you what are you going to do in the
event of your storm
both of you said like oh what are you
going to do i'm trying to figure out the
plan for tomorrow
can i depend on you to be here tomorrow
uh not absolutely no the answer is no
right right okay
that's what you should have said instead
of feeling all guilty
i don't really feel guilty i know
just say no i can't be dependent upon
yes no i can't be dependent that's it
now
who can i depend on if i make it in
tomorrow fred yes sir will you be here
tomorrow
you make your every effort to get in i
will be here i was here the day after 9
11. i was here during several blizzards
when there were no cavs i don't have the
problem that gary has all right so so
fred i can depend on you to be here i'll
be here and what are we going to do if a
tree falls on gary's house
how's it going over there
man the kids are in the house
i can't hear you right now i'm busy
taking down the treats my priority
all right thank you gary